back here now man backstage the force 30
into 30 in Detroit every teller thank
you man for joining me first and
secondly congrats again to becoming a
new CEO of Kickstarter make sure y'all
download the app he asked me to say that
right make sure you download the app
um congrats man it's a big deal yeah
thank you it's still settling in this is
you know day six for me in terms of work
days and um you know it's it's it's
humbling to be in this position to be at
a platform that impacts so many people
in a positive way and to be able to come
here at the Forbes 30 on the 30 Summit
for my first this is my first speaking
engagement as CEO of Kickstarter and to
be in front of you know you know
thousands of incredible young leaders
um it was just a great opportunity
absolutely yeah what's it like to be a
CEO man I know he was off camera chat
about cartoon LLC if you see what it's
not the same like you're a CEO of an
established company man
it's a huge responsibility you know for
all of the love that I got last week I
also got critiques from the company I
got a lot of feedback I am now the
person when people have a problem I am
the person and what people don't
understand being in a CEO role is that
everything's your fault
everything's your fault no matter what
you have to be able to take that
responsibility it's a huge
responsibility that comes with that and
so
there's the glitz and glamor but what
people don't realize is that it's a huge
responsibility you're responsible for so
many people but then you're also
responsible for a platform that impacts
millions of people or at least in my in
my regards so for me that's a lot of
responsibility every day I wake up and I
have to make sure that I'm doing what's
best for them right right like a lot of
times you in your life become secondary
because you have a responsibility a huge
responsibility to your users to your
employees to their families and
everybody that that impacts so that's
the big responsibility on the other side
it's cool to be the boss absolutely it's
cool to be the boss but yeah well as
they say but it's cool to be a boss but
often you've never taken a private jet
before you never take a private plane
I'm gonna need you a CEO now to talk
take that private plan listen man but
listen this is where the responsibility
comes in right it's because you lead by
example right me taking economy tickets
or me not staying at fancy five-star
hotels says look I'm willing to walk the
same way that you guys do right that I'm
I'm willing to I don't see myself any
different than you guys and that's
extremely important you have to be a man
of the people not only for your users
and your audience but also internally as
well and so that's important you make
those sacrifices sometimes for the
greater good and to show that you know
the company means more than your own
individual wants and that's really
important but again like it's really
cool to be the person that has with all
that responsibility you have the ability
to impact the business in a way that you
just can't in other c-suite you know
roles absolutely how do you scale a
company like what is that like I hear
the phrase all the time and I know what
it is but yeah you can do it well it
depends are you talking about scaling a
company that's Kickstarter size and
growing it or
it really fundamentally comes down to
understanding people what people don't
understand is that you know I said this
to some of our users that they gave you
know critical feedback I said I've made
a very successful career by literally
just listening absolutely you've seen
you've seen so many companies and they
do things you're like are you listening
to your users are you having any just
casual conversations because if you're
actually talking to your users and your
customers you wouldn't do that yeah and
the data doesn't even reflect that right
and so for me I think scaling a company
always comes down to what we just talked
about on stage finding product Market
fit being able to effectively Reach
people where they are right you need to
know where your communities your users
the people that you need to reach are at
you know if you're trying to build a
company that is you know for maybe an
older crowd you probably shouldn't be on
Tick Tock right right like you should
understand your audience where they live
in these online communities and be able
to engage them effectively but then also
bring them into experiences that are
going to be engaging and keep them
retained a lot of people they reach some
of those communities but then they bring
them into an experience so that product
and that marketing flywheel you know
it's a catch-22 for sure yeah when you
were out there and you were just coming
up with the concept of starting your own
company back when you were young every
teller right yeah
um what was that mindset like man take
me through that transition of because
there's a lot of people out there they
work and they dream of starting their
own company they dream of being a CEO
but they just can't get there how do you
get there
honestly you just you just gotta have
the willpower
you know what's interesting about
Kickstarter and what inspires me so much
about Kickstarter is that we actually
give people a platform where they don't
have the excuse yeah if you need money
you need the resources it's right here
and for me I just never allowed myself
to have or make excuses for myself I
never
allow myself to get down on myself if I
had an idea or something that I felt was
a great idea I wanted to go go for it
there's a bunch of companies that didn't
work out or I didn't get funding for I
was I was I just met a few VCS over here
before I went on stage and I was like
hey you guys actually turned a company I
co-founded down a few few years ago you
know what was their reaction when he saw
it was it like okay they were they were
like what really you know they they were
surprised and they were like wait we got
to get you to meet you know someone and
I'm like you know that's part of the
process and so I've had a lot more
failures than wins but what I will say
where I've been effective at is that I
haven't built these multi-billion dollar
companies that I found it but I've been
able to identify a problem be able to
find out where those users live and
create products that had product
marketed fit that were actually
effective and be able to scale to you
know smaller profitable companies not at
the size of Kickstarter but still
smaller profitable companies and you
know we were Haroon on stage he's a g i
mean he's amazing he's incredible most
people can't sell a company for a
billion billion dollars but listen I
tell people all the time have smaller
goals right if you can build a company
and you can pay your rent say you still
got your other job you can pay your rent
off of your company or you even your
your your car bill or whatever and then
loans it might be the car bill then it's
paying your rent and then it's wait wait
I'm paying all of my expenses just from
this company yeah right and then boom
now you're making maybe 250 300K a year
if you look at the world the average
income in most places is like 30k if
you're making 250 300K good life running
a company that's incredible thing and so
I think sometimes we have unrealistic
standards and it doesn't have to be that
way you know run your own race you don't
have to be like anybody else and just
continue to climb and move up yeah and
part of that human part of to the people
side right you say The Willpower right
you have to have that but another thing
that especially you live by humility yes
right the humility side of it going into
a door and knowing you don't know
everything right exactly why is it
important to keep that humility and
especially at a high level because
people people can tell when you're not
real yeah they can feel it what's
interesting about Kickstarter one of our
biggest categories is like games and
tabletop games and stuff like that I've
never played like Dungeons and Dragons
and all of those things like that super
cool but I've never personally done that
I'm playing my first tabletop game like
RPG game
this week with my engineering team wow
and I'm excited I'm gonna be doing that
for three hours
in the zone in learning because I want
to be authentic to whatever I'm doing I
come in and I said to that audience I
said listen I'm gonna keep it real with
y'all I don't know this you know I don't
know this space but I'm Gonna Learn and
I'm Gonna Learn better and just give me
some time I'm a quick learner five years
ago I I bought my first art piece I
didn't know anything about art and now
look at me right and so if you're going
to really invest in that but also be
real with yourself that you you know may
or may not know something
your audience is going to respect that a
lot more and see the effort that you put
into actually getting to know that space
let's ever tell the superpower
I think
empathy man
I think empathy on both sides the
ability to empathize with customers
users people generally like being able
to understand their pain points the
things that they need to be successful
the things that they want right things
that bother them the things that make
them feel insecure those are all things
that you need to know
when building a company and on the flip
side leadership is all about empathy
we talked about that private jet thing
right
what is it going to look like to my my
team if I'm out there flying a private
jet that's empathy man that's that's
being able to put yourself in someone
else's shoes and think about how they
feel before you act or speak and so to
me the ability to empathize with anybody
from any Walk of Life to me is my true
superpower in 2022 coming to a close
almost yeah you CEO of Kickstarter now
what's the soundtrack what's the song
that you that's motivating you heading
into 2023. oh man you know what it's
it's click it's Click by Jay-Z Big Sean
Kanye because I can't do it alone I
can't do this alone like I have to have
an amazing team and so I want to get
them hyped up I want to get hyped up and
know that like we're in this together
and you know the lyrics I'm not going to
say it but you know we're going to kill
it man absolutely thanks my brother
thank you appreciate it
foreign
[Music]